hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Plato's me know there are four sets
of passages that are that are returning
to the same themes over and over again
and slightly reworking them and what I'm
going to do in this core concept video
is is try to bring them together in what
I call a close reading this is a
particular way of reading and sometimes
writing that philosophers do other
people in the humanities do this as well
and it's a close reading of a text so
that means remaining very close to the
actual text itself and trying to use the
text in order to understand other
portions of the text one way that you do
that is by looking across a given text
for the same themes coming up in
multiple places and see how they're
treated if there's any sort of
development going on if things actually
started out better and then you know
went in the wrong direction later on in
the author's mind and so what we want to
do with this one these these three
themes of Goods and desires and
knowledge keep popping up over and over
again in this this discussion which is
really focused on two
other things well three other things can
virtue be taught what is virtue and the
doctrine of recollection but you see
this this set of themes coming up
numerous times and I actually put the
references here hopefully you could read
it with a little bit of with the themes
that are a little bit of the background
what's what's being talked about so
let's look at that first let's look at
these four passages so the first one is
actually two different references and
these are coming in
Nino's attempts to provide some sort of
definition of a virtue and Socrates will
keep on asking him when he tries to
define virtue he first tries to define
it in terms of social roles and I'm
gonna do a different video on these
these arguments so I'm not going to go
over these arguments much Annie says
well virtue is when you're doing what
you're supposed to do the thing that
corresponds to your role so Socrates
says well is that all there is don't we
require in order for somebody to
actually fulfill the role like you know
husband or wife or child or servant or
you know director or old person or pick
whatever you like don't we require are
we looking for them to be acting them to
be doing what it is that they're doing
with justice and with temperance and
Meno suppose again I think that's that's
the case well then you know that means
that they actually have to have certain
virtues or they have to be acting at
least in accordance with certain virtues
in order to be virtuous as a whole this
doesn't work for defining virtue but
we're not really concerned with that at
this point so we want to keep that in
mind another discussion comes up a
little bit later and this is one me I
was trying to get his his third
definition of what virtue might actually
be and he says something like well the
virtue is actually desiring
and acquiring good fine
noble honorable things the Greek word
has come along and it has you know wide
range what much wider doesn't say the
beautiful or the noble but but we have
to kind of you know make do with them
anyway
me note is saying virtue is this this
having the right you know desiring the
right kind of things and being able to
acquire them and Socrates points out a
lot of interesting things having to do
with desiring good and bad things and
with our beliefs about those and so I
actually want to look at those passages
very very briefly because they're
they're quite interesting he says
something that I think is really on
point and this is where we start to get
to the the meat of the issue so he says
here we go when you speak of a man
desiring fine things do you mean it's
good things he desires I mean uh says
yes so he says then do you think some
men desire evil another desire good
doesn't everyone in your opinion desire
good things so this is a typical
Socratic viewpoint and this ties in the
flesh but over here Socrates and it
appears Plato thought that people desire
what they take to be good so if you know
they never desire something because they
actually think it's an evil thing they
never say I want that because it's bad
they want bad things on occasion but
they want bad things because they're
mistaken about what actually is good and
what actually is bad so the desires are
stemming from a incorrect or false
belief so he says do you really think
anyone who recognizes evils for they are
for what they are nevertheless desires
them me no actually says yes and
Socrates says desires in one way to
possess them he says in the belief that
evil things bring advantage to their
possessor or harm and you know
some you know in the first beliefs
awesome also in the second so me know is
actually expressing a more you might say
common sensical view and this is dealing
with the what we call the problem of
across iya the problem of weakness of
will the problem of making bad choices
Meno is holding out for this view that
yeah actually some people do desire bad
things and they desire them even knowing
that they're they're harmful Socrates is
going to go the other direction with
this and he says those who suppose evil
things bring advantage do they
understand that they're evil and Meno
thinks about this a moment he says well
no I guess they they don't see insofar
as they think that the bad things the
evil things are actually bringing about
something good they are understanding
them to be good so he says isn't it
clear that in this class who don't
recognize evils for what they are
they don't desire evil but what they
think is good even though actually it is
bad those who through ignorance mistake
bad things for good
obviously they desire the good they
don't desire the bad they desire what
they think is the good they actually end
up desiring that they had but they don't
see it as as the bad so Socrates goes on
a little bit further on and he actually
says you know those who are gonna get
bad things who desire bad things they're
gonna be injured by them they're gonna
be harmed by them and if they're harmed
by them they're gonna be unhappy and he
says does anybody actually want to be
unhappy and then the fortunate you know
the answer to that is no he says so if
not nobody actually desires what is evil
for what else is unhappiness but
desiring evil things and getting them
and this is a really interesting thing
to say so what is it to be unhappy its
to get bad things but it's to get bad
things because not some but not because
somebody else force them onto you in its
core it's because you desire the bad
thing
because you mistake the bad things for
being good things so unhappiness for
Socrates is always going to be a
function of ignorance or foolishness a
lack of information lack of accurate
information about what actually is good
and what actually is bad or something
you know even more disordered with them
within a soul so that's an interesting
discussion that ties in with this notion
of making proper use a little bit
further on talking about you know
acquiring good things if those good
things are actually not to be harmful to
you you need more than just getting the
good things you know that's one thing to
desire bad things you know like say
drinking poison alright if somebody
drinks poison it's not usually because I
say yeah I want to poison myself that's
a great thing it's because they said
well I need to die so I can protect this
you know secret or something like that
or my life is no longer worth living and
they see the drinking of the poison
itself is leading to a good or I'm going
to show them I'm going to spite them
that is beauty as there the good that
the evil of the thing that's being you
know consumed gets sort of lost in you
might say now there's a lot of good
things and we're going to talk about
these different goods in a moment
there's a lot of good things that are
not unqualifiedly good they can turn out
bad for you depending on the
circumstances so what makes sure that
one will actually make good use out of
the good things that you acquire well it
turns out that that's going to be some
kind of virtue some kind of good moral
condition some kind of good state so he
goes on a little bit and he says he
gives these examples justice or
temperance or piety so you know being
fair following the rules doing what's
what's what's right or you know being
able to room
restrain one's own desires keep them
within proper limits or having the right
relationship to the divine those are the
sorts of characteristics that will keep
a person from misusing the good things
that they actually do acquire and this
ends up you know of course leading to a
problem too because now you need justice
or you need piety or you need some part
of virtue in order to define virtue but
again we're not we're not that worried
about that it's very interesting that in
order to actually make use of the the
good things that you have in order to
make use of the things that you acquire
and do in fact desire you need more than
just the the desire you need more than
just the getting you actually need the
virtue or else things are going to go
topsy-turvy sooner or later the next
passage shows up much much later and
this is when he is actually in the
course of the discussion about thinking
of this virtue a kind of knowledge again
he returns to this this theme of the use
of good things
what will I actually make sure that we
make use of good things and here we
actually see a little bit of progress
it's not enough just to have justice or
temperance
or piety or the other you know various
virtues that we're going to list on the
board in a moment like courage great
soul nose nobility of character those
sorts of things there's another virtue
that's needed in particular one which
sort of permeates the whole virtue for
for Plato and we'll get to that in just
a moment the key point here is what
we're seeing again is the same theme
that showed up in the first passage
showed up in the the third that shows up
in the fourth this notion that in order
to make good use of things in order to
actually not screw up to to order
properly the
things that you actually are lucky
enough to get your hands on you need
something that goes beyond those Goods
you need another kind of good the good
that actually makes those Goods
unqualifiedly good in that context
lacking which those Goods can turn into
bad things harmful things for you the
other thing that he says is and this is
very important virtue is what makes us
good so that goes against any sort of
notion that simply by acquiring goods we
become good its virtue that makes us
distinctively good as human beings so
we've got all these different passages
in mind let's see if we can start
disentangling them and tying them
together one one good not what I want to
start with are two things you notice
I've got these sort of charts here
and I didn't fill in this chart over
here because that's that's where we're
we're heading towards traditionally from
the time of Plato on a common division
between types of goods in philosophy in
ethics has been between external goods
goods of the body and goods of the soul
so you know what would be external goods
wealth is a great example Socrates
actually talks about gold and silver in
this case you can think about a nice
sort of property offices or power there
it's it's you know your your
relationships with other people things
that you have as part of your community
which are not really that much about you
we could add something else to this - if
you had reputation or honor that would
fit in there and then in this
traditional classification what about
goods of the body these are a little bit
more you there a little bit closer they
can take your money away but that
doesn't necessarily take away your
bodily characteristics you know they
take enough money
perhaps they'll cancel your gym
membership and then you won't have
necessarily strength
we're examples of these health health is
is a fundamental good that belongs to
the body it makes other things possible
but it's clearly just a matter of the
body for somebody like Plato strength of
the body something a little bit
different than health because you can be
strong without necessarily be healthy
being healthy and it can be healthy
without necessarily being strong and the
third one then doesn't go with with
either of them by by necessity but you
know sometimes accompanies them good
looks these are actually good things
that belong to the body and you know
they belong to the person but they only
belong to the person insofar as they
have a a body they're not the most
lasting goods in some respects they're
they're more lasting less easy to lose
than these external goods but they are
still fairly easy to lose
what about goods in the soil now
Socrates does talk about things like
good memory
you know quickness of width those sorts
of things well we might call
intellectual faculties intellectual
gifts and talents that sort of thing and
I suppose we could also add although he
doesn't talk about this in here certain
skills or knacks that we have certain
talents what is really interested in
with these goods of the body would be
things like our good good of the soul
virtues like justice courage
temperance
hi Eddie we could go on and on and up
great sold in this he talks about quite
a few of this this dialogue turns out
now are these things themselves
unqualifiedly good where we also have to
add something else in there well that's
where we're going with this so we want
to go back to now thinking about this
this idea about using using good things
acquiring good things having good things
and then remaining good things for us
how do they not remain good things for
us but we use them the wrong way we
order them in the wrong way we do the
wrong thing and trying to acquire them
Socrates will actually say if it means
acquiring gold and silver unjustly then
the virtuous thing is actually not to
acquire them so there's some goods where
the acquisition of them you know
depending on the circumstance is by
itself introducing some sort of bet and
it's it's harming the person who gets
them probably harming a lot of other
people in the process but it's harming
them in other ways it's not harming them
insofar as they get well right but it
may harm them in in respect to their
body it'll definitely harm them in terms
of their soul if they're doing the wrong
thing they're damaging their soul so
what about things like goods of the body
can these go bad yeah I mean you can you
can make health or good looks or
strength into a greater good than it
ought to be and sacrifice a lot of other
things to it particularly particularly
your character your decisions your
relationships to other people that ought
to be managed the goods of the soul so
they can go wrong can health ever turn
out to be a bad thing for a person and
so on some circumstances
good looks you know if you just get by
and your good looks your whole life
probably not going to develop very much
in terms of your soul now like Socrates
points out people desire good things
these sorts of good things why do they
desire them because they believe that
they're good their beliefs are a little
bit mistaken quite often in that they
think that these things are always good
or the fact that they're good and
helpful advantageous to us in some
circumstances means that they're always
going to be good so wealth is a great
example wealth is a good thing you do
need some money
you do need some property to get by in
life
will merely having wealth or the process
of acquiring wealth always be a good
thing if it were unqualifiedly good then
it would always be a good thing but
that's not the case so if you have a
mistaken belief about the nature of good
things about the nature of these kinds
of things external goods because of the
body that's the soul well you're going
to make bad use of them sooner or later
you're going to screw up in the
acquisition of them sooner or later
you're going to mess up your your way in
which you you possess them they may come
to possess you you might say so what
determines whether we make good use so
again let's go back to these these
questions one possibility is that we
need these virtues in order to make good
use of it
now these virtues are not all actually
on the same level this is something that
Socrates and Meno are not actually
talking about here but I think you have
to sort of read between the lines to
figure this out oh yeah this is that
matter
close reading paying very close
attention what's going on courage could
turn out to be a bad thing if it's
genuine courage then it's not going to
be a bad thing but there's things that
look like courage but aren't really
courage there's a matter of sort of
foolish confidence and just think about
gags we get into fights all the time
where people who get into all sorts of
you know altercations that they don't
need to be in and end up suffering as a
result even some goods of the soul if
they're not properly understood if
they're not properly informed it could
go bad she doesn't say that about
justice he does say that about
temperance I think maybe something that
would be a can of facsimile of justice
could certainly go bad you know the kind
of people who always have to be right
and it's less about them actually
aligning themselves with with what
actually is right and it's more about
them you know having to have sort of
superficial relationship with rules so
that they can be better than or over
other people that would be affect
similarly of justice that wouldn't
really be justice what's needed
according to Socrates and he says this
in this fourth section in order to make
virtues really work is something that he
goes back and forth a little bit on he
uses two different terms
knowledge and wisdom this is what you
need in order to make the virtues the
goods of the soul the what he calls
psychical or spiritual characteristics
good that is what actually makes them
good according to Plato according to
Socrates so if you don't have knowledge
or wisdom and wisdom itself is one of
the virtues by the way if you don't have
that then the justice the courage the
temperance the piety that you have are
not really going to be entirely what
they want to be your courage might
actually be something more like full
hardiness or it might be courage just in
certain circumstances not when you
really want to have it and these are
going to rule these so if we wanted to
sort of depict it in a kind of chart
form let's do it like this
wisdom governance the virtues which are
good
and those virtues make sure that we make
use of other goods so belief or
knowledge getting our head straight
about what it is that truly is good and
when it is good and when it's bad and
when we have to watch out for things
that's something that's very important
because if we don't have this everything
else becomes very unreliable
according to to Plato in this this this
dialogue at least that's what he's
suggesting if we don't have wisdom or
you know some sort of knowledge
something better than mere opinion we
are belief then our what virtues we have
are not going to be properly informed
and they we could make bad use of them
and they are not going to govern making
right use of these these other Goods and
then we're probably not going to be
happy because what are these what is
this stuff structure well all of this is
structuring how we make use of how we
follow whether we indeed have or don't
have and what degree we have designers
when we think something is good we
desire it when we realize that something
actually isn't good or that it's only
good part of the time we don't desire it
or we desire it less and if we have you
know to put two things side by side and
we realize that say virtue is a more
important good because it actually
determines what you do with these other
goods it's more important than these
other goods we desire both of them we
should desire virtue more strongly that
would actually be the wise thing to do
so wisdom actually and these virtues
bear on desire
which then he has to do with how we use
these these Goods so again this is a
what I've carried out here is what we
call a close reading are you going to
find Socrates at any point in this
dialogue saying exactly what it is that
I said no I've taken a bunch of pieces
and I've kind of put them together in a
coherent account which is a you know
typically Socratic or platonic thing to
do some sort of rational account and
said if these these parts are going to
be like they are the whole of them that
we put together has to match up this way
so this is a good example shot this
video in parts of my students can
actually get a handle on what this idea
of close reading is as well as this this
set of interesting topics so that's
where we'll leave